Eigentlich befinden wir uns ja gerade
in unserer Winterpause, denn,
wenn ihr das hier seht,
befinde ich mich gerade
in meinen Flitterwochen
auf der anderen Seite der Weltkugel,
in Neuseeland.
Ich freu mich so.
Ich wollte euch eigentlich
nur ganz kurz frohe
und entspannte Feiertage wünschen
und ein guten Rutsch ins neue Jahr.
Außerdem möchte ich mich
bei euch bedanken,
dafür dass ihr immer so coole,
konstruktive, witzige
und sehr oft unglaublich schlaue
und intelligente Kommentare schreibt.
Und das muss ja erstmal sagen können,
über YouTube Kommentare.
Der aufmerksame Zuschauer weiß, dass
ich versuche, mir die Zeit zu nehmen,
die Kommentare auch zu lesen und sie
auch immer wieder zu beantworten.
Weil mir dieser Austausch
eigentlich ziemlich viel Spaß macht.
Deswegen dachte ich,
vielleicht mach ich mal ein Q&A.
Ein Ask-me-anything.
Und nutze die Winterpause,
um eure Kommentare,
um eure Fragen zu sammeln.
Also, ask a way. Ask me anything.
Normalerweise stellt ihr mir ja
vor allem wissenschaftliche Fragen.
Das könnt ihr auch
nach wie vor machen, ask me anything.
Ihr könnt aber gerne auch
irgendwas anderes fragen.
Zu mir privat oder
was philosophisches
oder Ratschläge für euer Leben.
Was auch immer euch einfällt,
alle Fragen sind erlaubt.
Ob ich sie dann beantworte,
das ist eine Frage für sich.
Am 11. Januar geht es weiter.
Ich habe noch eine Folge
Science-News für euch in petto.
Ihr könnt aber hier oben abstimmen,
was ihr zu erst sehen wollt
am 11. Januar:
Science News oder das Q&A.
So oder so werden die beiden Sachen,
die ersten beiden Folgen
im neuen Jahr sein.
So viel zu meiner
Weihnachtsansprache.
Ich wünsch euch was, bleibt sicher,
wir sehn‘ uns 2018.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)